okay hey everyone it's evan uh i have a
special treat for you today over the
past little while i've been working with
an entrepreneur a friend of mine named
jen who has a copywriting business and
i've been coaching her and helping her
along the way along the road she's
growing
and
i said hey why don't we make this public
so other people can learn who are facing
the same problems as you
and also maybe give your business a
little bit of exposure so we're gonna
we're gonna try to see how it goes this
is this is our fourth call i think so
i've labeled it number one because the
first being recorded but it's a fourth
call um
jen maybe you want to just give a quick
intro so the people who are watching
know what you're all about and then
we'll get into it yeah sure so um i'm a
copywriter and i've been working with
evan on copy for his new um branding of
his site um
and uh
yeah my business is you so much and uh
i'm
excited to work with you evan
okay so i guess uh
recapping everything that's that's
happened since the past couple months
we've been working on
coming up with
a marketing pitch being able to clearly
identify
what it is that you do so other people
can understand it and and connect to it
so it's not just words something that
people feel and then actually going out
there and
starting to get clients built this
business from the ground up so yeah
how are we doing on the on the pitch
good good so last time you and i talked
um
we talked a little bit about refining my
pitch to kind of down to one word
um and we were kind of going back and
forth between or i was going back and
forth between touch and sexy
um because i feel like my copy the thing
that differentiates my copy is that it
really lures people in and it makes it
more enjoyable for people
um and so my whole thought was i helped
them sell something and i helped make it
enjoyable for their customers so the
idea was
you know the the
thought behind touching and sexy was was
that i really help you touch out touch
your customers and make them feel
something and um
and after further thought since our last
conversation i really have been thinking
about like what i really enjoy doing is
and i've touched on this before as i've
called i call myself a dream teller
because i really love to
work with entrepreneurs and tell their
dreams too right so the idea is i want
you to express what your dreams are
so that your customers can relate with
that and then um
feel like you're
you have a connection with them and so
thinking more about that
um
i do feel like entrepreneurs have a hard
time like really expressing what their
dreams are like they um you know they
they say that they want to have a
business but they don't they don't know
how to translate even further they don't
know how to make it make it more
tangible and i love to be able to write
that like write the story about what
they um
really want to do what their real
desires are what their crazy dreams are
right and so um i thought about that and
what i really love to do is write
fantasies and and fantasy is kind of
like something that it's kind of a fun
word
it might have some of the connotations
that people
don't really think it's related to
business but i love it because i think
it it taps into what someone's desires
is you know not just necessarily what
their what their dream is because dream
has such different connotations but
fantasy really leads into like
what they really really want you know um
and i feel like that's really that
that's really what i do i think that's
what i do best so i think fantasy is my
word in fact i know it's my word
okay cool
well we already have a couple people
watching this this is this is good um
okay yeah fantasy it's interesting
so fantasy to me
it kind of seems like something that is
unattainable you know like i really want
that to happen but it's it's in a
fantasy world but um
no it's good if you love it that's like
i'm all about believe and people will
will question that
and
i don't have any doubt like i i i can
explain it and
uh i love that word so if you know
people are gonna say fantasy what how
does that make sense for someone who
does copy
uh so as long as it feels right
the
the way you talk about it uh may kind of
change over time as you get used to
expressing it sure
but it should feel like if somebody
comes and said now fantasy is not right
for you
you should feel
like you've been wronged like that's a
that's a big right
i love that right yes
is that there like is that
i say now fantasy that's too unrealistic
for business owners and people you're
talking they won't understand fantasy
i i don't know i like it because i think
what it does it really taps into
someone's
into someone's desires right
i help you write what you who you want
to be but i also tap into what your
customers want to be you know i remind
them of of what their dreams are and
encourage them to go after them and the
idea is if someone reads your copy on
your site they are like fulfilling their
fantasy it feels more real to them and
then it encourages them to go after it
and if they're encouraging to go after
it that means they're taking action that
means you you know things are
transpiring
sales are happening right so um
i don't know i in that way i feel like
it's it's perfect because i i tap into
it to what you really want as a business
owner but also what your customers
really want
okay
cool i like the passion
this is a good start so the next thing
is now that you have that definition
is when you are thinking about working
with clients
people will relate to that word very
well
and others will say you're crazy
sure and that's okay you want the people
to say fantasy yes that's what i want
this is great
uh i think of i i don't know one that i
don't know a brand that thinks you know
fantasy means fantasy to me but um i
think of disney where it's make dreams
come true sure yeah for some that kind
of connects with me so
is there a brand that you can think of
that is all about fantasy
i mean the only brands i can think of
are probably more or more sexual
oriented right like a fantasy shop or
something like that so that's the one
thing that kind of made me think gosh
i'm not sure if that if that's going to
turn some business owners off but i
think the other reason why i love the
word fantasy is that i want to write a
book i don't know if i've ever mentioned
that to you and the kind of genre of
book i want to write touches on fantasy
also so to me it just like fits me
really well um and i think that like you
said the right customers that are
attracted to that word will hopefully
you know feel connection to that too
yeah it does have that kind of
connotation you know fantasy novels are
a genre so people will associate it with
that
that kind of mentality um but but part
of your role is also explaining how it's
more
when i talk about believe people think
it's just believe in yourself like have
right
that's what most people assume but it's
more than that for me it's also believed
that you're doing the right thing
mm-hmm starting the business not just
for money but because there's something
that needs to get done and you believe
in that cause
right and then also believe that if you
keep going you'll be successful that
even if if it's you know you always see
this darkness around you and you're not
getting any momentum but if you believe
that if you keep going you'll see the
light at the end of the tunnel
so three components to believe for me
where most people only see one
it's probably the same thing for you so
fantasy
you know you have that side of you that
most people will relate to but then
if there's two or three other things
that it means to you you know expressing
that clearly
on your website and when you're doing
videos and talking about it so people
understand
yeah
i agree all right i'm writing this down
jen fans okay all right
fantasy
okay well it does elicit
some
it makes you think right it makes it
puts you in a place it makes you feel
something so that's
that's good it wasn't what i was
expecting but that's okay it's not
good okay that's good so how can we
start using that in in the stuff that
you're putting out you have your website
are you doing anything with your social
media
not a lot i just have started doing a
little bit um and i've thought about
maybe
doing more with my facebook page i am on
twitter um so i'm not doing a lot you
know it's funny i actually have i do
have my website out and have some copy
on there they and actually do i have
something that kind of reflects this
philosophy of mine but doesn't really
come out and say the word fantasy so
obviously i think it'd be good if i put
a blog post out about that um
and what's really funny is someone
recently contacted me they somehow found
me through google and um hired me to do
some copywriting for them so and one of
the things that she said really spoke to
her on my site was was the idea of being
bold and um
and finding pleasure in your life and so
all that kind of to me relates to
fantasy as well so um so yeah i think i
think you're right though making that
more clear on my website and talking
about fantasy copy
um would be good to kind of help
translate that word a little bit more
yeah and you want people who will
search
for fantasy
right and they may think they're crazy
like why am i searching for fantasy but
it's what comes up
yeah
so here's an example i was looking for
an artist for um
for for my guides right so you've seen
some of the guides yeah
one of the guys is about thinking big
and encouraging entrepreneurs to go
after
bigger deals because we tend to be stuck
in these little tiny deals all the time
and we don't have the confidence to
think about bigger deals so i wanted an
artist to help me create a painting a
digital portrait at the top that would
reflect thinking big if there was a
stump or whatever something something
about thinking big so i'm i'm searching
on google like thinking big artist
right right trying to find something
right and nothing came up and i was
struggling so there are people who will
be searching for this kind of stuff who
are looking for
you know copywriter fantasy and
you'll come up now right if you put this
on your website you make it all about
that you'll start to show up right
so it's great for the website um
for
the social media stuff what i love
what i'd love for you to do is start
building a movement around
fantasy okay
why this is important in your life why
like what's the mantra like what's the
fantasy mantra that you want people to
connect with
well
to me it means like
making your fantasies real because i
feel like um
once you write things down they become
real um i think you even talked about
this in one of your recent videos you
were talking about how people you know
they say they want to be successful but
they don't have anything tangible right
they don't have like a business plan or
whatever but it's even more than a
business plan it's actually like
having a story in front of you that that
makes you feel like your fantasies are
coming real like that is super powerful
and and can make things really happen
for you in your life
um and that's kind of that's kind of my
mantra like you know when you write it
down you write down your fantasies they
can they can become real you just have
to it helps you feel them
it's good i like it i like it so
what i'd love to see is this movement
around fantasy that is built around you
where you're encouraging people to make
their fantasies come through and part of
that of what you do is copyrighting but
right it's a powerful movement that you
are helping to
to lead
and for people who
maybe don't feel they have a fantasy or
are
trying to find it
right we can look to you as someone who
inspires them and helps them
okay the content that you share
i'd love for you to share
work that you're you're doing for people
right work that you are helping people
out with uh if it's you know copy on
this on the side or this new client you
have or whatever share some examples of
it
and explain how that relates to
fantasy
okay
right so ideally now all of your clients
somehow relate to
fantasy because this is what you do you
know you don't want to write boring
stuff that is not related to your
mission
yes
right
so like any artist
and what you do is art you know it's
it's maybe not seen as art as much as a
painter but what you're creating is art
you often have to explain your art
to show how you got here and that people
understand you better uh so if you're
creating a blog post you're quite
creating a tweet um
it'd be great to see
what went into it so
the creative process or how you included
fantasy in this and and everything that
you create now should be related to
having
people believe that their fantasies can
come true
right
cool i love it
then i'd love to see other
things related to fantasy that also
inspire you so it's not just your work
mm-hmm great it's one thing but i'd love
to see other if it's quotes or pictures
or books or
sayings or famous people or a moment
that happened to you on the street or
something
yeah relates to fantasy that you can
share
for your audience
i love that idea yes
so
i mean if you look at my my twitter feed
i'll have
i'll have my own quotes and stuff on
there but it's also
inspirational pictures or quotes or
other stuff that relates to believe that
that my audience likes so
right at the beginning it's you talking
to yourself you know it's like right
right
totally no i know yeah there's also ins
it helps keep you motivated like when i
when i read the quotes that i put out
it keeps me believing
in what i'm doing and so
that hopefully will serve to inspire i
mean that's how you know you have the
right word if the stuff that you're
sharing that's about fantasy is
still keeping your dream alive and what
you want to build and making that dream
of yours come true
okay
um
so
i mean it's easy to get bogged down and
overwhelmed with social media and and
all that stuff but it'd be great to see
some kind of regular
contribution that you can write
um
even on twitter like once a day if you
could share something that relates to
fantasy somehow it doesn't have to be
deep you know deep meaning yet you're
still kind of getting your feet wet and
getting used to it sure
but
if fantasy is what you're all about then
there's a lot of things in your life
that are related to
fantasy
yeah
your
your job your you know your business the
books you read
so it's finding something on a regular
basis to be able to share
uh with your audience that
relate to fantasy for you
yeah i agree it's funny because i i
think that a lot of people just are
afraid to like really delve into what
their fantasies are they you know they
sort of have them but then they just
like they're afraid to have them for
some reason they don't think that they
can have a dream or they think it's too
big of a dream like you're saying think
big or um or whatnot and i think you can
even have little fantasies and they can
come true like i mean i've started doing
this since i thought of the word fantasy
i literally started writing myself small
fantasies and it's amazing how many of
them have come true i mean just little
things um if
they've manifested themselves so i
really believe this like if you write it
down and you have them you you focus on
them they come true
i like that message too if you write it
down you're that's like your first step
to making it happen
yeah that's something that could help
inspire and encourage people who
don't believe that it's gonna happen
yeah we're helping them with that that
very first step
um that's great i love that that can be
like a repeating theme
uh and whenever you know it sparks you
can write something about it
yeah
okay this is cool this is good this is a
good start um how are we doing with all
the other stuff that the companies are
following up with the spa client the
local companies all that stuff
it's coming along good i feel like i've
got some momentum going which is awesome
um
i felt like i was sort of dragging a
little bit because some of the companies
i was reaching out to you know were like
oh i know i'll give you the name of that
person such and such you know
you know i'll email you back and i
finally just started you know actually
you kind of inspired me in one of your
videos you said something like do
something every day do something small
and i was like yeah let's do something
small just go into you know
business owners and just see if i can
talk them and and um so i've been trying
to you know three or four times a week
just go visit a local business owner
that i don't know i mean i know a lot of
business owners from my current job but
i thought to really build momentum just
talking to more people
and um and it's been helpful i've met a
few business owners and you know a lot
of them said oh it's the holidays come
back and see me in january which is fine
but i feel like i got the momentum going
and so um so i'm talking to local
business owners and i'm still in process
of i know one of your suggestions was to
um write some copy for an aspirational
um company like a bigger company so i'm
still in process of writing that copy
and i haven't done the video yet for
that but i definitely want to do that
um but i definitely feel like there's
momentum going which is awesome okay
have you thought about who the company's
going to be
yeah well um i really like the idea of
um the true and company is the name of
the business it's a lingerie company
and um they have some good copy on their
main website but when you look at the
product descriptions they're kind of
boring
um and i think a lingerie company is a
great company to write fantasy cafe for
right
it's good i like it yeah yeah because
their their copy for their um their
products are it's kind of boring it just
has a description
you know of the different items and it
there's so much room there to write a
story like try a little mini story for
each item so that's kind of what my goal
is
cool have you approached them yet
no i have not you don't know anybody
there no i know nobody there are they
local
no they're not okay yeah okay so this
was this is the aspirational client
we're to make a video and then show them
what you're doing exactly yeah okay
so when is that going to be ready
um i'll have it ready but the next time
we talk how's that
i said that last time but i think so i'm
looking at my notes i'm pretty sure
that's what you said last night it is
what i said last time but i have to say
i got a little distracted with the
fantasy which which is okay because i
feel like it um it put me in the right
direction i feel like that you know now
i feel like i know what i'm doing
it's good and you had picked that
company before you picked the word
fantasy so it's interesting yeah yeah
so i felt it i felt it was the right
company so yeah
yeah cool
and i have talked to um
my um client and friend willow at um
willamina modern apothecary and she has
an awesome natural skincare line um
and she also she has a website up with
products but no descriptions and a
similar kind of thing and she knows kind
of where my goals are and um my ideas of
actually she had touched on fantasy a
little bit with her and she loves it so
i'm going to be writing some product
descriptions for her on her website too
cool that's great
my my goal for you i would love to see
this fantasy movement take off so it
becomes a marketing magnet for you so
you're not constantly having to go out
to talk to businesses but people will
self-identify and say wow this is great
i love what this woman stands for and we
need to hire this person
yeah
so
yeah starting the movement
cool
so
what can you do on your website to bring
fantasy into it a little more have that
word
show up and people quickly understand
this is about fantasy and copyright
well i think immediately i could
probably um
have a tagline of some sort up near the
top that says it right away
somehow
um because right now it just says
emotion touched copywriting
okay so i could re rephrase that a
little bit so it's more about fantasy
right so now you're different right
because every copywriter will say i like
to put emotion into my copy nobody's
talking about fantasy
yeah
this is good you're different
i like it it's good okay
um i don't want you to go and spend tons
of money on on fixing up your website is
there something easy that you can do
like can you do that yourself or is it
the quick fix that you can
have your person do yeah that it's
definitely a quick fix i'm sure
okay
yeah
cool
uh and then i guess gearing the whole
homepage copy towards
fantasy yeah
i agree and there's i think the copy on
there is
really geared more towards the name you
so much um which i still like but i
think i could i could rephrase it a
little bit so that it does fit in with
fantasy okay
cool so can that happen when's that
gonna happen that will happen this week
how's that right
good
this week and then the social media
stuff so you already have your account
set up you're just not using them mm-hmm
it's what it's off your name or you so
much or what
well
yeah it's under um rockstar gen
which is another name that i've used a
lot um
so i might change that
i don't know if i should change the what
do you think should i change the name do
you think it would make sense to change
my name so it actually has fantasy in
there unlike a twitter account like a
twitter handle
um
i like building personal brands yeah you
know so i i like even your name unless
that's already taken it's hard to get
twitter accounts now yeah um but i
tracked the evan carmichael on
everything
and i
people know that i stand for believe and
that comes out in everything that that
but
it's kind of
so you've got fantasy you've got
rockstar jen you've got you so much
right i know how many different things
you want people to remember right like
rock star gen like rock star means
something else yeah right i mean it can
be tied into fantasy like you want to be
a rock star or something whatever um
but
it's kind of holding two separate
thoughts it's not as easy to
communicate yeah i agree especially if
you're at the early stages and you don't
have a lot of followers or any kind of
activity to switch it up now is probably
the best time to do it
um
i would probably switch it to either
your name
or fantasy gen or something like that
something that something like you should
get excited by looking at it yeah
cause even you so much
uh
you asking people to remember you so
much and your name and fantasy so that
already is
yeah
i agree if it's closer to my name
that'll be awesome i know jennifer price
is taken and you so much is also taken
um
but
i i thought about doing gen so much
um but yeah i'll play with it i'll play
with a name that i think works but i do
like the idea of branding myself and
then having fantasy is as as the message
mm-hmm
like you so much
uh
at least to me maybe you could tie it in
like it has to tie in somehow because
you created this and you're all about
fantasy so it relates somehow but it
seems like a different concept
yeah
like usually i think you so much as like
you could you can fulfill your fantasies
you know what i mean it's all about you
you know
but yeah i need to think about that more
the language around that
yeah
you know what when i started my business
my website was off of my name and and
and for a long time i actually regretted
it because it was just a personal
website at the start and i just talked
about where i was from and what i was
doing and it was was not a business
um and i just used it because it was
convenient and
and then i regret it like i wish i used
entrepreneur in there somehow or small
business expert or something like that
in my domain name
uh
and now i'm so glad that i didn't
yeah
because the personal brand is so
powerful right
you can make it built around you and
people get to know you your face they
see you on videos they hear your message
it makes it a lot easier to want to work
with you want to share what you're doing
so
it is a concern
it's nice to have some kind of
consistency across the board with your
social media stuff i agree
what do you think of when you think of
you so much like to me i have my own my
own feelings and thoughts around that
but
uh use some i i guess my first thought
would be you could you could do so much
you could be so much it's kind of
uplifting
yes
and it does relate to fantasy like you
wouldn't pick something that's totally
opposite of fantasy because
you made it so right
yes
but it's like is that the main thing is
that your main message or not um
you know i wouldn't associate it to a
copywriter but that's fine like you the
whole point here is to get a feeling and
then you inject what your specialty is
to help them
i agree um
try to work the copy somehow
to incorporate you so much into fantasy
uh but the social media stuff becomes an
issue where you don't have
you so much or
or your name right right
like yourname.com
no i don't i don't even know if it's
available i don't know if i've looked
that up i've looked up uh
other names around jen but um
that's interesting i don't know
yeah or or um
or jen instead of jennifer
right
uh the domain is for sale
jennifer price.com's for sale anyway
yeah yeah
if i can incorporate my name jen into
into you so much or into fantasy somehow
i like that idea
or uh do you have a middle
initial or name or anything
yeah my middle name is lura which is my
daughter's name too so that would be
kind of confusing
well you could be like
jen l price or something right or jenna
lou like that's what my mom calls me
yeah
as long as you're comfortable you like
you're fine with jen or jennifer uh some
people like do not call me jen you know
right right so that's fine um but if
you're okay with that that being your
name then it might be worth looking at
if you can get all of those across the
board and the domain name
you know people i guess are finding your
website um as illustrated by that client
that just came in yeah
but this is still like ground stage
right this is still so early
and having something powerful and easy
to share
uh goes a long way to helping word of
mouth spread for you
i agree
okay i'm gonna write that down
okay
good new names
social media handles
okay and then what about thinking on the
types of content that you can create
so you can start i mean you can even
start now with whatever you have and
then if you switch your account until
you're moving but
what kind of
think about facebook or twitter what
what can you share
that relates to fantasy that will help
people who believe in the same thing
feel
inspired and ready to act on something
yeah i mean i love the idea of finding
quotes um
to share on twitter and also um
on facebook i know people on facebook
love like the little you know like
infographics or you know little you know
graphics of quotes versus just actually
putting something on twitter but it'd be
cool if i could find like other content
across um other websites that talk about
fantasy or dreams coming true or writing
things down
um
that i could put links on from twitter
for sure
and facebook really
yeah um
you don't have to go out and create your
own stuff yet you know uh
time and budget is always an issue you
know yeah
so for sure
we'll hire somebody to make these for
you it's okay to share what's already
out there
um
i like the story idea and especially if
you can also
hashtag the author or
at symbol the author
yeah that you're sharing your stuff
their stuff and like a quick sentence as
to why you like it
because these are also going to be of
like mine to you
because they wrote something that you
enjoy
and just getting on their radar screens
could lead to something
right
the other thing i could do and i've
talked about this a little bit with
jason is just write like a little mini
entrepreneur um fantasies like sort of
that are related to um
you know businesses that might want to
hire me um you know what are some of
their fantasies and kind of like so they
can connect with that somehow
um
you know i don't know if that makes
sense to put on my site somewhere or if
it's um
you know
i'm not sure but i love the idea
yeah it should be something that gets
you excited like if you read it you say
yeah that's that's
hashtag fantasy right like you get to
define what hashtag fantasy is
right
sharing that
um so if you write something and that's
that's what it embodies and yeah you
want to share it not everything that you
share has to be related to you writing
copy
right that's part of it and you're
sharing your your copywriting success
and stories but
sharing things that that inspire you
motivate you
are
great like that's what's going to help
spread it too right
so what's what's reasonable could you do
like one thing a week
that you could post to facebook and
twitter yeah okay
i mean ideally i'd like to get you to
once a day or even more than that but
yeah
i don't want you too much and then
you're uh not doing anything right right
i agree but i could i mean i think i
could easily do two or three a week i
mean i guess one a week is a good goal
and then hopefully i'll exceed that
yeah okay yeah
because if i'm sharing other people's
content that to me seems like i could
easily do that you know a couple times a
week
versus doing my own
like once a week to me is it yeah
okay and give it the hashtag hashtag
yeah i love it
good
um
so i think that's good do you have do
you have other thoughts or questions
um no
no not right now
okay so what i've got here on our list
until our next call is
thinking about the fantasy kind of
mantra a little bit more and defining it
and tightening it up
uh put it on your homepage
and fixing that copy
uh once a week social media
shares with hashtag fantasy
and looking at domain names slash social
media handles around something that you
can brand
okay
on top of aspirational copy for chewing
company i know yes yes
holidays are here i know right
i've got nothing else to do
no it's okay well i'm i'm excited for
your progress i can feel the excitement
in your your your voice too about
fantasy i was i i wasn't initially sold
on the concept but but hearing your
passion for it brings me in so it's good
good
fantastic
so here we go two weeks okay all right
look the next time and for those of you
guys watching we've had viewers
throughout kind of pop in and out and
we'll have more who kind of come in
online and watch afterwards we get to
see jen grow
awesome
thank you so much evan i love your
suggestions i'm excited talk to you soon
okay bye